a true icon celebrating a brand new
album coming out attention and pride I
should be so lucky I like what you did
there I was not expecting that I'm very
unexpected Kylie you'll figure that out
throughout this interview yeah okay
we're starting there we're gonna go
it just goes up from there okay go
wherever we like that's right this
honestly is so iconic thank you so much
for sitting down with empty Canada I
just I can't believe we are having an
intimate conversation for the next half
hour I know let's do it let's do it
albums we are going to chat the album in
a little bit but tell me when you hear
that number 16 what goes through your
mind how high up is this chair because
you know I I I it's quite surreal to me
um
yes I don't really
for me before I make the album it's just
it's the next album It's the next burst
of creativity and
um if all goes well it will be the next
kind of year two years of your life and
it's been the past year year and a half
um but yeah when you say 16 it's
I didn't I didn't think that would
happen I didn't I didn't you know I made
a demo when I was 17. I loved pop music
I wanted to get into it and um
and here I am 16 albums later and here
you are 16 albums later and I think that
what it says about you Kylie is that
after all these years you are still at
the top of the charts and at the top of
the game you are an icon worldwide and I
don't just throw that word around you
truly are an icon why do you think and I
know it's hard to reflect sometimes and
pinpoint things but why do you think
Kylie has remained we've seen so many
talented artists kind of come and go but
you have remained
a good question I don't it's like a
magic trick I don't I don't know the
answer I don't think anyone knows the
answer but I do know that I
am determined and I feel like
over time I have amassed you know my my
toolkits
got a lot in it now just have experience
there's a
a phrase I really like which is there's
no shortcut to learn your craft and so
I started young so I could kind of make
up a lot of time but
um how do I I don't know I I love change
yeah and I remember getting
kind of quizzed
about that a lot years ago like what so
you you have these
you know you you um
you have these reincarnations and I I
couldn't quite get my I said well I'm
just growing up you've got to know me
when I was
a teenager and so going through early
you know your wild early 20s and you're
like so grown up at 25 and then you're
you know all the different moments so I
love to be aware of what's around me and
absorb that and try and shape it
to me I guess I'm pretty malleable
authenticity is a word that comes to
mind when I think of you Kylie and you
have had as I mentioned this epic career
that people have dreamed of but the
thing I love about you is you've managed
to stay
humble I feel like there's a real warmth
around you and a spirit that connects
you to so many people how have you
managed to stay that way after Decades
of success
because I am that way because I
genuinely
feel that and I think as time has
progressed it's
you know you can make people feel good
feeling happy and have that
that experience hopefully Joy is the
word that gets I mean I didn't that
wasn't my ammo that wasn't my
thing I was trying to do but it seems to
have just happened over time and with a
collection of
um yeah a collection of songs and
memories and experiences and concerts
and ups and downs and everything in
between everything in between I have to
tell you and I would hate myself if I
didn't disco was an album
that really took me out of some darkness
in my life it was such an important
album for me it's an album that I still
listen to at least once a week it really
is I think a highlight in your career
for me personally it is that album for
me
I'm so
touch that you share that with me
because it was lockdown you know we all
experienced that and
I've made most of disco and lockdown
which is
ironic but we'd already called It Disco
and we were going to see that through
um
and to have not been able to really get
out and
do how you do the promo
um but
have that exchange with people and it's
it's you know it did it it affected
people and I'm really glad that it
affected you thank you it really did and
thank you for the album you know I think
you have had a huge queer fan base for
the majority of your career but I feel
like you have so many more fans now from
an album like disco did you expect that
album to connect on such a personal
level with so many people no can you
imagine no we at the start of that album
it was just what's next you know we'd
I'd done golden which was the kind of
country uh tinge pop album which was I
think really instrumental in getting me
to where I am uh now and a lot of people
love golden for I loved the therapy of
it and learning more about songwriting
um you know I spent time in Nashville
and that was it really
changed me
um
so yeah here we are we get disco we're
at the Disco I like the Disco and now I
think we're in the club this is why I'm
wearing this everybody we are in the
club we're gonna talk all about
attention you know you have had a
dedicated fan base of the queer
Community for the majority of your
career as I mentioned uh why do you
think so many queer people connect with
Kylie I know why I do I know it might be
hard for you to pin it's really hard for
me I mean if you're happy to share what
is view that would be great but for me
it's um it's just been really natural
beginning an evolution and
um
I mean I was kind of adopted
when I heard there was a Kylie drag show
in Sydney in 1990 or whatever it was and
um that's kind of the first I heard of
that
that kind of thing I didn't get to go I
really wanted to go over and I was like
saying to my manager gotta go is that um
I don't think
you would need a bit of organization
I've since been to a few drag shows and
trust me I'm the least Kylie in the room
like I've got
I turned up to a Kylie drag show Once
later in the 90s and I was just kind of
very
it's part of me that's like pretty kind
of hippie earthy and I think I was in a
very
natural moment I'd been to see the
Lemonheads that's what it was and
um ended up at this Kylie thing and I
was like oh my God I am just invisible
everyone's looking at the drag they were
well I I went on stage with them but I
really thought you are you're out
calling me by
you know you're stratospheric and I've
just rolled in I love that but try and
answer your question how how why I
I don't know and I'm asked all the time
and I'm no closer to the answer and uh
I would say around that time in the 90s
I mean we can talk about my career now
and you know you you kind of forget the
moments that work right you know Rose
tinted glasses and everything
um but there were plenty of moments
where I was just being absolutely kind
of
mm-hmm it was it was not pleasant and I
feel like
my gay audience felt some kind of
solidarity that I think I just want they
protected me and I was trying to give
out nothing but goodness and when you
when you cop it it let alone fairly I
think they're ready to bite